tu as toi tu joues bien mais tu un souci
c'est que tu connais mon écoute pour ça
que tu divorces souvent on était tous
dans la loge et forcément il ya toujours
un mec qui fait le malin et le maire ont
fait mal bizarrement c'est toujours
marrant moi qui serai toujours un
hommage à mike à cela dit il a voulu
faire le malin il a voulu me battre au
ping pong mais je dis écoute on va
attendre et je vous proposer quelque
chose ce soir en direct là tout de suite
vous pouvez miser sur benjamin castaldi
va faire un match en trois points
dakar 4 points 5 points 5 3 6 6 1 54.47
moins 8 mois 3 0 on devrait être en
vacances là on est là on bosse et on a
plein d'infos je suis prêt à payer 10
contre 1 tous les chroniqueurs cd rom
était un euro sur castaldi vous en donne
10 ha ouais vous en mettez disent je
vous en donne sens dans m'étais san jose
en 2000 exorbités mille je parte
[Rires]
si vous perdez tout l'argent je prendrai
la personne qui aura fait le hashtag
benjamin castaldi et une banane n'est
pas un gage d'avenir anr est une maladie
et je lui offrirai tout l'argent que
j'aurais récoltés je suis un petit peu
ric-rac mais je peux te dire à mes naim
donc un sac banane julien courbet cinq
balles dont je paie mon ticket de métro
oh non mais aucun de ces valeurs
cycliques mais je connais la valeur d'un
exercice manquons ya à l'élan à l'italie
à bari j'ai que ça joue bullois le
sursaut de l'agglo à aller chercher
l'argent mais bien aux distributeurs
je les ai perdus mais je suis prêt à
miser de nouveau 5 euros donc si tu
gagnes tu viens de 50 balles près
d'accord bon j'ai que deux ou trois
petits ne passait pas d'argent cinq
balles mais derrière de losail le machu
picchu trou
le bal de la ba oui mais si j'ai plus je
donne plus bas est lui à mon avis frère
non là sur moi mais je t'offre une
séance d'uv joffre joffre dix fois le
montant total aux gens qui nous
regardent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention c'est un 5 3 tiens vous allez
servir vous voulez que je sers allez-y
je vous en prie
enlève plutôt slip
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non mentalement il est très faible tu as
eu un truc bien tu vois toi tu joues
bien mais tu un souci c'est que tu pas
ni mon écoute pour ça que tu dis voir
souvent elle espère bien pour un bon
alors
[ __ ] mais c'est à vous n'avez pas de
mental castaldi impliquer tous aussi
bien ses fonds à chacun des quatre
points alors franchement j'ai trois
paradis perdu là non c'est la fête
propose un truc je vais prendre mon
iphone j'ai c'est de marquer le dernier
point l'iphone
bâle est ok t'as pas un gros le groupe
je vois d'autres jouent pas mieux avec
sa globalité ben ça va le faire
non
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]